hey guys I'm Eric Vox and this is a
breakdown of Sherlock series 4 episode 3
the final problem may be the final
episode of Sherlock ever but gone Benny
and Marty gotta have at least one more
Christmas special in them right now
there's a lot to talk about with the
final problem some clever callbacks to
past episodes and literary references
but also some parts are just straight-up
confusing so I'm gonna explain as much
of this as I can and point out some
interesting stuff along the way so let's
get started with the opening images so
this episode opens on the eye of the
little girl who's trapped on the plane
who we learn later is a metaphorical
version of the isolated little girl
inside URIs Holmes is mine now this
episode shows the journey of URIs
learning the value of empathy gaining
emotional contact and throughout the
story URIs is mostly seen watching with
fascination as her brothers make
impossible emotional choices so it's
fitting that the opening shot is her eye
as she peers out at us then the familiar
voice of Jim Moriarty returned
well
final problem now the adventure of the
final problem is the title of the book
by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle that features
Sherlock facing off against his arch
nemesis Moriarty he invades his rooms
and plays tricks on him and his friend
it also features two to one be Baker
Street getting burned just like in this
episode but really the story version of
the final problem has been an
inspiration for a lot of moments
throughout Sherlock so like Sherlock and
Moriarty first meeting at the end of the
great game then the series 2 finale the
Reichenbach fall which similarly ended
with Sherlock and Moriarty confronting
each other and seemingly both of them
dying and then the abominable bride
special episode featured a scene at the
actual Reichenbach Falls from that story
but really this episode is pulling more
from another Conan Doyle short story the
adventure of the musgrave ritual and
I'll talk more about that later
so this finale is really light on
references and links to the short
stories and it's more about tying up
loose threads and making callbacks to
other episodes of the show so for
example this airplane full of
unconscious maybe dead people is a
callback to a scandal in Belgravia where
Mycroft fills a terrorism targeted
airplane with corpses to avoid
casualties and avoid alerting the
terrorists that they prevented it ok now
moving on through this weird scene with
Mycroft home being turned into a spooky
house of horrors all of which is
apparently an elaborate ruse by Sherlock
to get him to confess that they had a
sister ok probably an easier way to do
that Sherlock but really there actually
is the reason for all of this so this is
easily the biggest Mycroft episode that
we've ever gotten on Sherlock and one of
the many things that we learn about him
is his love of theatrics so notice what
type of film he's watching it's a
stereotypical American War detective
story this signals to us that Mycroft is
a sucker for Hollywood style gimmickry
so knowing that his brother is otherwise
completely closed off Sherlock and said
relies on these visual cues to get under
Mycroft skin in a different way all of
these horror images are iconic Hollywood
tropes this little girl is wearing a
blue dress just like the twins and the
shining there's a killer clown like an
it and the walls bleed like in the
Amityville Horror
and then notice how the camera rotates
slightly which is
cliche Hollywood horror camera movement
and Sherlock specifically uses the
context of a ghost story to provoke a
confession about yours because Mycroft
has already turned URIs into a ghost
story for Sherlock telling him
throughout their lives that the east
wind is coming to get you which is a
trigger phrase at Mycroft invented to
make sure Sherlock bill didn't remember
her turned my sister into a ghost story
but before I move on just a few cool
things I want to point out about the
sequence first if you listen closely as
Mycroft freaks out at the new footage
that spliced into the real you can hear
the actress say this line I think this
is a subtle foreshadowing of URIs this
episode a prisoner who's free to escape
but chooses to be in the hands of the
authorities to lure her brothers into a
trap also we see that Mycroft has this
dope sword hidden inside his umbrella
which screws up again into a tiny
handgun that could be a reference to the
British spy show The Avengers from the
60s and 70s where John Steed also hid a
sword in his umbrella I'm guessing that
for Mycroft got the idea finally this
painting that bleeds looks like it's of
Sir Isaac Newton and I think this is
another foreshadowing of yours because
later this episode Mycroft says this
about her yarosh was described as an EVA
defining genius beyond mutant so I think
seeing Newton bleed specifically
triggers Mycroft guilt for burying away
another Newton level genius and for
those of you wondering how Sherlock
makes a painting bleed like this no time
to explain moving on now check out this
moment between Mycroft Sherlock and John
so these guys have always been super
subtle about their emotions with short
lines and miserable reactions instead of
like long-winded monologues that's why
he stays
now Sherlock's line here is intended as
an info to Mycroft like this man has
been more of a brother to me than you
ever have but John smile here speaks
volume he'll take any compliment from
Sherlock that he can get now for years
we've wondered exactly what the
relationship is between these two men
and now it's confirmed they're brothers
you know and this scene here answers a
few questions that we've had one share
inferred is indeed the name of the
facility that holds us share inferred
was Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's original
name for Sherlock and many scholars
believe that
at Sharon furred would be the name of
the third home sibling so it's cool to
see the show repurpose the name like
this also we get some insight into why
Sherlock is the way he is so notice this
line from Mycroft every choice you have
made if you're positive taken the man
you are today is your memory of humans
so what does this mean Sherlock is a
detail obsessed sociopath observing
everything in attempt to solve mysteries
whereas Mycroft said that as a boy he
wanted to be a pirate Eurus is the one
who changed that she killed red beard
later revealed to be his friend Victor
Trevor leaving behind a haunting
mysterious song that Sherlock could
never decode that event traumatized
Sherlock on a subconscious level making
him feel like he must decode every
mystery save every future red beard and
before I move on we get a reference to
this line truces Randy pure never simple
which they later recall is a line from
the play The Importance of Being Earnest
which is written by Oscar Wilde
now that play is a forest where
characters take on fake identities the
irony of course being that no one in the
play is Being Earnest with each other
and that concept extends throughout this
whole episode with characters taking on
fake identities specifically Mycroft
falling back on his experience playing
Lady Bracknell also fun fact Oscar Wilde
and Arthur Conan Doyle were
contemporaries who actually met in 1888
and many believe that Wilde influenced
Conan Doyle's writing to make him more
bohemian bohemian is a polite British
Way of saying dead T or Irish and it's
kidding
British people aren't polite about
anything that's Talib reads not London
Bridge stupid Americans
moving on to share inferred the island
prison clearly modeled on places like
Alcatraz or Azkaban or the raft or Sea
Gate for Marvel every cinematic universe
has an island prisons that people
inevitably break out and real quick here
I like the callback of Sherlock finally
getting to embrace his childhood fantasy
of being a pirate my name is Sherlock of
the detective
the park also remember Sherlock gave up
his desire to be a pirate as a young boy
when URIs traumatized him so embracing
this pirate dream now signals that
Sherlock is going back in time mentally
regressing from detective Sherlock to
Pirates Sherlock a boy who's forced to
connect with his sister and let's jump
forward to that confrontation so this
whole scene between Sherlock and Eurus
is designed to mirror another
confrontation between Sherlock and
Moriarty in the Reichenbach Fall and
both scenes Sherlock is trying to suss
out how exactly is nemesis got away with
something while Moriarty and Eurus have
similar responses what's the fun of club
I did tell you particulars I need to
know how you got out of here you know
already look at me
also both confrontations feature
Moriarty and URIs chastising Sherlock on
his violin renditions of Johann
Sebastian Bach Johann Sebastian would be
appalled he clearly doesn't understand
it's a news and the big mystery of this
scene is how the hell did Sherlock not
noticed missing glass like I know you
refused the throat Mike and carved out
the parts of the glass that had words on
it and that Sherlock had to stand a few
feet back forming this kind of Indiana
Jones and the Last Crusade style
perspective illusion but I would say
that ultimately this jump in logic pays
off because for one it's a pretty cool
surprise to see these two siblings hands
pulled into each other and then to yura
says this line
so observing the unobservable but
missing the obvious details right in
front of them has always been a key part
of Sherlock's character it's why he
needs John Watson and this tendency to
overthink things is a trait that URIs
imbued in him when they were children so
naturally she's exploiting it now okay
moving on to the cruelest bait and
switch on Sherlock the return of
Moriarty followed quickly by five years
earlier come on at least make him like
Mary Watson mind projection or something
rather than just you know like tick
tocking on TV screens all episodes and
the big question of this scene with URIs
Moriarty is who's manipulating who here
did URIs request to speak with Moriarty
so she could reprogram him to destroy
Sherlock with a specifically laid out
set of plans or is Moriarty using the
home brothers sister to deliver his
promise to burn Sherlock and to be
honest I kind of hate this answer but I
think it's both so check out this shot
of yours and Moriarty doing their weird
face to face mirror snakes and yours is
reflection it's superimposed on top of
Moriarty face and I think that implies
that their goals are merging becoming
one in the same so yours allows her
desire for revenge to be appropriated as
Moriarty's final problem Wow Moriarty
agrees to be an instrument of chaos for
the Holmes brothers outside of the walls
of Charon Forge all right let's move on
the structure of this episode resembles
something closer to the great game
Sherlock has to go through a series of
puzzles a death trap all while Moriarty
taunts him with the countdown and each
of URIs is puzzles references short
stories from Arthur Conan Doyle the
three Garrideb brothers references the
adventure of the three garridebs where
three men pretend to be named Garrideb
but only one of them is telling the
truth and the kauffman of Molly Hooper
references the coffin mysteries from the
short story the disappearance of lady
Frances CARFAX and really on top of
being kind of Sherlock's version of saw
there's two deeper things going on
throughout this series of puzzles one is
URIs unlocking Sherlock's capacity for
emotion and empathy she's testing his
heart with each step becoming more of an
extreme test so saving the governor's
wife by killing her husband tests
Sherlock's empathy for an innocent
stranger then the Garrideb puzzle tests
Sherlock's
empathy for a guilty stranger the coffin
puzzled
sure loss empathy for the dignity of
someone he cares about and then the
ultimatum with John and Mycroft tests
Sherlock's empathy for the two people he
cares the most about and the reason URIs
is doing this is since she can't feel
emotion she needs Sherlock to use his
ability to feel emotion in order for him
to connect with her to show her the love
that she never felt also there's a more
subtle emotional arc occurring
throughout the sequence ironically
coming from the least emotional source
by cross so from the moment Europe
leaves Sherlock a gun with one bullet
left
Mycroft superior reasoning predicts the
inevitable conclusion Eurus is going to
force Sherlock to shoot one of them so
from that point forward
notice how unlikable and unhelpful
Mycroft behaves he sarcastically mocks
John's knowledge of firearms I've done
doctor what's not useful you are Joe has
officially being made to compete and he
heartlessly suggests that they just let
the girl crash the plane in the ocean
getting the plate away from any mainland
any populated areas past Christmas II
then in the final room he cruelly orders
Sherlock to shoot John and filthy and
Sherlock's intelligence ashamed so
ashamed family name ever once in her
life do the right thing put this stupid
little man at Imola loud three now
eventually Sherlock sees through the
charade but it's impressive to see
Mycroft long game here selflessly
characterizing himself as the lesser of
the two men to make it easier for his
brother to kill him from the moment
Sherlock snaps that's why he stays
Mycroft is understood that John has
replaced him as the brother that
Sherlock depends on and then take off
this moment when Eurus brags that Morey
already predicted this decision to shoot
his brother
he was so excited Iliana
the end of the line oh now Sherlock
seems to defy that prediction instead
turning the gun on himself
but when you think about it Moriarty
friction is still technically right
Holmes is still killing home and I think
this shows that Moriarty truly does know
Sherlock Holmes better than anyone okay
moving on to the final part of your
puzzle returning Sherlock to his
ancestral family estate of Musgrave it's
time to solve the Musgrave ritual I
mention this before but the adventure of
the musgrave ritual the Arthur Conan
Doyle short story is the inspiration for
all of this that story features a rhyme
that passed down through generations
that conceals a treasure hunt around the
Musgrave estate there's even the same
specific line sixteen by sixteen and
really the concept of the hero returning
home is a critical step in the
archetypal hero's journey and we see
this a lot with British heroes in
particular where the idea of ancestry
and lineage is especially important to
one's identity in fact the recent movie
Skyfall
similarly brought home another iconic
British hero Daniel Craig now in this
case Sherlock Holmes must return to the
tragedy that began history the
disappearance of Victor Trevor at
Musgrave now bitter Trevor is the name
from the Conan Doyle short stories as
well he was an early friend of home from
school in the adventure of the Gloria
Scott and many scholars actually believe
that the Gloria Scott is Holmes's first
case in the books chronologically
speaking so it's fitting that this
Victor Trevor story is Sherlock's first
mystery in the show as well and the show
uses a few very interesting visual
choices to underline this realization so
for one noted now the colour temperature
changes when the dog transforms into the
boy in Sherlock's memory it goes from a
warm yellow colour implying Sherlock's
golden nostalgia turning into this dull
blue temperature dragging this memory
into the tragic presence as Sherlock
realizes the truth also I love how Eurus
connects all the moments that deep water
haunted Sherlock throughout this show
holy
we see images of the pool in the great
game that's where Sherlock first met
Moriarty we also see the Reichenbach
called from the abominable bride as well
as the aquatic imagery that Sherlock
associated with doom in the six statures
and then going back even further if you
remember the great game referenced
Sherlock's first case in the show
timeline the death of carl power he was
a schoolboy swimmer who drowned after
accidentally poisoning himself so really
throughout Sherlock's whole career he
keeps finding these images of deep water
and it all stems back to Victor's
drowning now this episode also shows us
a bunch of shots of the girl in the
airplane whom Sherlock is about to
realize is really just a metaphorical
cry for help from urine if you really
paid close enough attention this episode
was kind of hinting at this from the
very beginning so like a Plane full of
dead people except one girl with zero
clues suggesting that the adults maybe
inhaled or ingested something that the
girl didn't or any explanations for how
this plane could stay airborne for
several hours of no one flying it I
don't think we were ever meant to
interpret this literally the show wanted
us to doubt the authenticity of all this
and I love the way Sherlock solved this
using the two key lightbulb moments from
the past two episodes uris says that she
had no one and the word no one unlocks
doors and Sherlock's mind the same way
the word anyone was a trigger and the
line detective anyone and then just like
in the sixth a church Sherlock's
knowledge of the Latin language sliced
his path as your left hand brother dude
I left him ammo I'm not I love you love
he loved there it was knowing that mo
was Latin for love and here is no one's
Latin translation being Nemo which leads
her lot back to the headstone which
contained the numerical cypher that
Sherlock uses to decode yarissa song now
as we move on to after the climax the
episode winds down by answering some key
questions about Sherlock as a character
like he finally calls Welsh Rod Greg
that's his correct first name and then
Lestrade says this about Sherlock he's a
great monster much better than that
he's a good one this line is a callback
to the very first episode of study in
pink the shuttle home is a great man and
I think one day we're very very lucky
might be a good one so this question has
been the central thesis of the show been
really the main interest of Steven
Moffat and Mark Gatiss does Sherlock
Holmes a man with brilliant deductive
reasoning powers have a heart and this
moment would Lestrade along with
Sherlock wanting to protect it further
Mycroft
Mycroft make sure you said caustic as
strong as you think she's and you should
have done better do this best all this
answers that question Sherlock Holmes
isn't just the superhero from the
mythology he's also a good decent human
being and moving on to this closing
sequence which is filled with references
and hidden meaning first notice how
Sherlock and URIs play a violin duet
together and the camera puts one
siblings reflection side by side with
the other the conflict between these two
characters began because URIs just
wanted Sherlock to play with her and now
she has her wish as Sherlock and John
rebuild two to one be notice how there's
a chalkboard and that's a reference to
Conan Doyle's the adventure of the
dancing men and the Viking on the floor
is a cameo by British rocker Paul Weller
and the final shot contains two more
Easter eggs the plaque reading Rathbone
place is a reference to Basil Rathbone
who's arguably the most famous actor to
ever play Sherlock Holmes he played the
character 14 times in movies in the 30s
and 40s also the sign above the door
reads gwj that was a wink from the
production designer aural wind Jones who
made a cameo by the way as a contractor
in the previous shot so the W J is for
his name's with the G being for Mark
Gatiss and Mark gannets and Steven
Moffat said that the purpose of this
final sequence was to set up Sherlock
and John as the versions of the
characters as they exist in the classic
stories with the whole BBC show being
the backstory that gets these two to
this point so it's fitting that the
final line for Mary Watson is this when
no one else fails there are two men
sitting arguing
like they've always been and they always
will the best and wisest men I have ever
known
and that is a direct reference to Watson
final line about Sherlock in the final
problem story where he called Sherlock
the best and wisest man whom I've ever
known okay that's everything I hope you
enjoyed these Sherlock breakdowns if the
show ever does come back I'd love to
make more of these videos so let me know
what you think in the comments and
please like and subscribe to new
rockstars and if you really like this
channel you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
patrons especially Kevin chaw Han we
love all you guys thanks so much you can
hit me up on twitter at EI vos has any
thoughts or theories you have about
sherlock or you can follow new rock
stars on twitter at new rock stars for
updates on when our videos are coming
out alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]